you said that you wanted to be ripped
after your time on dancing with the
stars so do you feel like you were
successful in that what else have you
gained along this journey yeah
definitely my body is
looking incredible
according to my husband and um and yeah
i feel i feel great i've lost like 12
pounds just without even trying i don't
even know how that happened
um i think i'm at my like body weight of
like 2008 when i was doing chicago on
broadway i think literally this is where
i am
um which is great and everything is you
know luckily i've been working out all
all my life like consistently so you
know there's like muscles that are
showing through now and stuff
so that's cool
um in any case yes that was great but
you know i would say that was like
that'd be like the lowest thing i would
say i've gained um i've gained so much
from artem like from just
the amazing dancing that he has
made me do and helped me do
and
helped me you know believe in and commit
to and give into and
learning how to dance with a partner is
so extraordinary it's it's just it's
unlike anything else it's a really
really fine line between learning to
give in and be strong but not rough but
not
but not too soft it's like you have it's
such a very beautiful
um
kind of metaphor for life you know you
gotta like
go for it a hundred percent but you also
have to be soft with it and you have to
be you know you have to be strong
without being muscling it and it's just
like it's really extraordinary and artem
is an incredible teacher an amazing
choreographer an incredible dancer i
feel like i've been so held and so loved
makes me cry
i'm
[Laughter]
um but ultimately i have such a great
friend
i think i really feel like we have a
beautiful friendship that will continue
and i got to dance every single week and
i got to be in the spotlight and wear
pretty costumes and
be the performer that i am you know born
to be so
that's been beautiful
adam what's your take on the judge's
save rule they seem to all hate it this
season because everyone is so good i
think it was designed to maybe get
someone who wasn't had low scores
you know but high votes and and they all
seem to hate it what's your thought on
on the judges say vote
um on the same vote
sorry can you do that
i mean well just in general where the
judges get to save someone throughout
the season what's your take oh i assume
having that with everyone being so good
um it's you know it's interesting
because i feel like the beginning of the
season the judges were scoring people
individually how they've done for
themselves they even commented i think i
remember even carry on saying we're not
comparing to against other people we
want to compare you to your last
performance
but i think that kind of changed a
little bit
through the season like especially i
think the semi-final today
i feel like i was kind of like i don't
think that kind of applies it anymore
because now i think they're directly
comparing people against other people
which is
is that fair is it not it's not my place
to judge but at the same time
like
does that mean doesn't matter how good
we try we're never going to get that 10
because somebody else is better like it
just kind of like
makes you sometimes feel a little
defeated i didn't feel like they were
judging our performance from who we are
and what we came from and how
how we how we performed tonight it felt
like instead they were just sort of
almost making random like random choices
about
uh about you know they said all these
incredible things but then the scores
didn't match the incredible comments
they made
which was a bit it was a bit
disappointing and upsetting because
i think we really danced like tens
tonight we danced both of our dances
like tens i mean all the pros came up to
me and said they've never seen
a female celebrity danced the rumba that
beautifully
rumba is a really hard dance to do it's
a really hard dance to do it's very
technical and it's got to be very flowy
and sensual at the same time that it's
incredibly technical
and i just don't think one gave you a
10. that's all it is and that was
important and beautiful and that meant a
lot because he was the mentor for this
but
and also he's the one that's so specific
about it being proper
as he says laura you're not hanging up
your dance shoes right now right you're
going to continue to dance
yes for sure i am i mean it'll be a
little bit hard without artem because
he's he's like my
like shining star in my dancing world
now but um
but yeah i mean and and maybe we'll
still find a way to do that um
i'm gonna get him to choreograph a a
video for a song that i wrote that's
hilarious um and we might even co-direct
it because i'm gonna need some help with
uh with making sure that we get the the
shots right and stuff
so um we are going to continue working
together i hope and and well we will
because
what i say is what i do
but um but also yes i would love i mean
i'm definitely gonna be looking for a
you know to originate a role on broadway
that includes a lot of dancing and
um or or a musical movie or you know
something like that because i do sing
and i am an actor and and i and i really
do all those things really well and
and i always knew i was a good dancer
but i don't think i knew
i was this good of a dancer
at 54.
yes
i think i think you know what i think
what's really hard is that i
[Music]
hate to bring an age up and i really
hate doing that because there's one
thing i've learned in my life like you
never talk about your age especially
when you're being in the show business
industry but
the one thing that i felt really sad
that
well actually very happy and various at
the same time i don't think that's been
for the past i don't know how many
seasons that the person at your age made
it that far
but the fact is
i don't know it's like i don't
understand why people don't get behind
us you know people who are watching our
show the core audience is is that our
core audience
like i don't know like it makes no sense
in my mind while women of your age would
not get behind and be like
i don't think i can do this and i'm just
so happy see someone doing it i'm gonna
go be i'm gonna stand behind i'm gonna
support it because
that's to me is like what's gonna make
me
maybe try the things or maybe say like
you know what
i can do it at 54
that yeah
because the end of the day i think what
is well hard to realize for some people
mueller can beat against people who is
three times less of her age
so when you see tricks and flips and
these things like i get it but it's like
you have to give some kind of
appreciation respect like
you just try as hard you just work with
just as many hours and the matter of
fact you do just as hard as moves none
of the day
dancing should not be just about visual
effects it should be about dancing it
should be about emotion it should be
about that and that's to me sometimes
very hard to understand why sometimes
audience
could easily be amused by a split
and not being amused by true emotion
that comes from a heart
that to me is very hard to understand
you